Deadpool 2 is finally here, and with it comes
more Easter eggs than an industrial hatchery.
It's no surprise that Wade Wilson would keep
the pop culture references coming fast and
furious, but Deadpool 2 also came with a pretty
wide assortment of secrets that you'd have
to dig pretty far into your comic archives
to find.
Gird your loins and prepare yourself for spoilers:
like a stolen prison pen, we're going deep.
X-Stuff
Deadpool's connection to the X-Men movie universe
isn't a secret… it's just a thing that the
serious X-Men films don't really acknowledge.
Deadpool himself is the world's biggest critic
of Ryan Reynolds' performance in X-Men Origins:
Wolverine, which he makes explicitly obvious
during the movie's mid-credits scene by pumping
a dozen bullets into the other, original Deadpool.
Deadpool 2 does everything it can to try to
weasel itself into the core X-Men movie world.
Deadpool wears Professor Xavier's Cerebro
helmet and says that it smells like the original
X-trilogy's professor Patrick Stewart.
He also zips around the X-Mansion in the Professor's
iconic wheelchair, and most notably, Deadpool
briefly stands in front of a room filled with
actual, real-life X-Men, including nu-Professor
X, James McAvoy.
It's the stuff X-Fan dreams are made of.
Essex stuff
Even though longtime X-Men foe Mr. Sinister,
aka Nathaniel Essex, hasn't actually appeared
on the big screen yet, his presence in the
X-Movie Universe looms large.
So far, he's only appeared in name.
By the end of X-Men: Apocalypse, his name
is seen on a briefcase and is connected to
the Weapon X facility that created Wolverine.
Logan's Transigen corporation, which created
Laura, aka X-23, has been confirmed to be
related to Essex Corp as well.
In Deadpool 2, Essex is the name of the school
that tortures young mutants, including Russell,
out of using their natural powers.
The bizarro X Mansion seems to be pretty anti-mutant,
so while their ideals don't really align with
the overall Essex ethos of mutant experimentation,
the name remains a common thread throughout
all arms of the X-Universe.
Goonies never say die!
Before he was Thanos, or Cable, or anything
else for that matter, Josh Brolin first appeared
on the big screen as Brand Walsh in The Goonies,
a fact that Deadpool will not let him forget.
Deadpool mockingly calling him One-Eyed Willy
isn't just a dig at his one peeper; One-Eyed
Willy was the pirate that the Goonies were
searching for in their own iconic film.
Want to double down on the Goon-love?
After Deadpool is torn in two by Juggernaut
and is recovering on the couch, he's wearing
the exact same shirt that Chunk did in The
Goonies.
It's all done out of love, of course: Ryan
Reynolds and Josh Brolin have a rare kinship.
Both starred in absolutely terrible DC movie
flops, Green Lantern and Jonah Hex, respectively.
Callback attack
Deadpool 2's many commercials revealed a whole
family-sized omelette's worth of Easter eggs,
but a few super clever ones were hidden in
plain sight.
When an exhausted Deadpool attempts to take
out a barrage of bullets with nothing but
his swords, that's actually a callback to
when he did the exact same thing, with much
more unbelievable success, in X-Men Origins:
Wolverine.
And yes, Deadpool finding a whole lot of cocaine
and the cure for blindness stashed under some
floorboards in Al's apartment is an unexpected
callback to the first Deadpool film…
"There's about 116 kilos of coca cola buried
somewhere in the apartment, right next to
the cure for blindness .. good luck."
He wasn't kidding.
Cameo city
Notably absent from Deadpool 2's many crazy
cameos was Marvel patriarch Stan Lee, who
only appeared as a mural on the side of a
building, and Deadpool 2's teaser trailer.
"Wow, nice suit!"
"Zip it, Stan Lee!"
One might have also expected Deadpool co-creator
Rob Liefeld to appear again after showing
up in the first film, but he's nowhere to
be seen.
"Buck.
Liefeld."
Instead, he's called out in a much more creative
way: as the creator of Domino, who Deadpool
proclaims to have a very stupid set of powers,
and was probably created by a guy who can't
draw feet.
Comic art historians will note that Mr. Liefeld's
grasp of the human anatomy is creative at
its best, hilarious at its worst, and more
often than not, includes large clouds of smoke
usually focused somewhere below each character's
knees.
"We have a minute and a half left I want to
tighten those feet guys.
Okay"
"alright guys?"
Noted Deadpool writer Gerry Duggan also gets
a shoutout: the parkway on which part of the
epic convoy battle sequence takes place is
named after him.
And yes, your eyes were not deceiving you:
that indeed was Brad Pitt - playing the ill-fated
Vanisher.
At one point scheduled to play Cable himself,
Pitt's cameo appearance and immediate death
were added in post-production, but are nonetheless
pretty unexpected.
Also unexpected is the surprise appearance
of Alan Tudyk, a toilet-paper obsessed good-ole
boy, appearing alongside Matt Damon, buried
under so many prosthetics that he's unrecognizable.
This, of course, is his second Marvel cameo
over the past year.
X-Farce
The sudden gory departure of almost the entirety
of the newly-formed X-Force is something of
a surprise… but it really shouldn't be.
Pretty much the exact same thing happens in
X-Force #116 when a newly formed group of
mutants calling themselves X-Force are immediately,
explosively dispatched, during their very
first appearance.
Among them is Zeitgeist, the same tattooed,
acid-puking mutant that's welcomed into Deadpool's
X-Force.
That tattoo of 116 on his arm wasn't just
an interstate, it's the issue where he died.
And we can't mention highly-specific numerical
references without Deadpool's prisoner number:
24601.
"Now prisoner 24601…"
Most significantly, it's the number of Jean
Valjean in Les Miserables, a role played by
Hugh Jackman on the big screen.
Bad taste
Deadpool co-star TJ Miller has been embroiled
in multiple controversies since December of
2016, including, but not limited to, calling
in a fake a bomb threat on a train, assaulting
an Uber driver during a political argument,
and allegedly committing violence and sexual
assault against a woman in 2001.
When the latter accusations surfaced after
Miller's prominent role in Deadpool 2 was
already in production, the film's producers
made the difficult and controversial decision
to keep the Emoji Movie star in the picture,
but axe him from Deadpool 3.
Still, the film couldn't resist taking a jab
at the situation.
During the news report about Firefists' explosive
meltdown, the crawl at the bottom of the screen
mentions that Christopher Plummer had turned
down a role in Deadpool 2.
Famously, Plummer reshot all of Kevin Spacey's
scenes in All the Money in the World after
Kevin Spacey was accused of sexual misconduct.
It's not like anything in Deadpool 2 was in
good taste anyhow.
"Noooo!"
Good taste
It's hard to tell exactly where Deadpool ends
and Ryan Reynolds begins, and it's a line
that's blurred constantly: Deadpool signs
a Wolverine cereal box with Reynolds' name,
and later shoots Reynolds through the head
as he considers ever even thinking about appearing
in Green Lantern.
But despite all of the movie's leaps from
different realities and tasteless jokes, one
throwaway line has more heart than the whole
film combined.
When Wade Wilson considers the name Connor
for his kid, it's not meaningless.
Prior to the original Deadpool coming out,
Ryan Reynolds enjoyed a special screening
of the film with a Make-a-Wish kid named Connor
McGrath.
While Connor passed in 2016, Reynolds made
sure that his love of Deadpool and his legacy
lived on in Deadpool 2 in the most heartwarming
and heartbreaking way possible.
Costume connection
While Deadpool is mostly known for his red-and-black
duds, he's fought crime in a wide variety
of colors.
While seeking membership in the X-Men during
Deadpool #16, he actually makes his own X-Men
uniform, with a giant, obvious X on the front.
Whoever designed the X-Men's trainee uniforms
in Deadpool 2 had pretty much the same idea.
Deadpool, during his darker X-Force days,
has also been seen sporting a black and grey
version of his familiar costume.
His charred costume near the end of the movie
is a dead ringer for his X-Force comics counterpart.
It's no coincidence: this is when the real
X-Force finally comes together.
Sorry, Shatterstar.
You suck.
O Canada
Because you just can't have Ryan Reynolds
in the room without making a few jokes about
his home and native land up north, Deadpool
2 has a few quips about America's friendly
hat, Canada.
Much more subtle, however, is a reference,
in name only, to Canada's number one crime-fighting
team, the never-mentioned Alpha Flight.
In this case, Alpha Flight is little more
than the name of an airline or travel agency
posted as a taxi ad, but the sentiment is
there.
And it's covered in maple syrup and hockey.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!